[Musique]
ça c'est un autre truc qu'on n'a pas
classé
il ya un truc que j'allais faire après
le pipe on de lui
on a adoré faire des expressions fait
d'être en scène des états unis on vous a
fait une petite compil regarde alors
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors valérie mais là il vous dit quoi
les sujets sont vraiment bien dans casse
investigations et moi je veux que tout
ce que vous dites c'est du flan
berne est absolument n'importe quoi ce
que j'entends je lui dis bravo parce que
c'est difficile avec votre merci
isabelle non non c'est pas le début
notamment est extrêmement gênant c'est
dommage
vous trouvez vraiment que c'était aux
côtés de trouver car nîmes autour d'un
café
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors nous vous avez pas chier dans la
colle
[Rires]
gfr
ce soir je pas ce que vous en pensez
mais j'ai pas l'impression qu'on [ __ ]
dans la semoule
cette année julia avec le csa on marche
sur des oeufs et un bel hymne tu serais
pas en train de me rouler dans la farine
la mise en scène léchée je veux dire de
toutes les façons quoi qu'il arrive quoi
qu'il se passe je garderai toujours la
tête froide
à
on m'a dit je viens de kent un micro et
bruce vous savez quoi je vais devoir le
payer et on va encore me prendre pour un
pigeon
[Applaudissements]
là les gens qui le rejoignent dans se
dire ah non là est vraiment au bout du
rouleau
eh bien oui